foreign
[Music]
thank you
chairman we are now live streaming
across the internet you're welcome to
proceed
thank you
thank you if I could open the meeting
welcome councils to the annual meeting
of council due to the ongoing
coronavirus pandemic meetings held by
the council will be done so virtually
for the foreseeable future
the out going chair councilor Huckabee
has asked me to open this year's annual
Council
can I remind members of the meeting
etiquette that has been circulated all
members should have their microphones
muted and cameras turned off
if you wish to speak on an item please
indicate this by turning on your camera
but remain muted the chair will then
call on you to speak at the commencement
of the debate
if you decide after this that you would
like to speak please turn on your camera
and lend to the word speak into the chat
function
can I remind them as to adhere to the
council's procedure rules when speaking
can I invite nominations for the
position of chair of the council
thank you Mrs Sternberg
this is Council Martin thank you
in 2005 councilor George and Cliff was
elected chair of this Council
his consort was of course packed
during her Civic year we saw them many
times
and quickly became friends
in the years that followed we
established a firm friendship
based on genuine care loyalty and
respect
although George is no longer with us
I'm sure he will be proud that 15 years
on
councilor Pat and Cliff would herself
become chair of Northeast Derbyshire
District Council
councilor alcliffe has a background in
the retail industry and education
she and I were colleagues when Pat was
appointed as an education social welfare
officer covering the area in which I was
a head teacher
within that role she demonstrated
kindness and compassion
along with a determination to make a
difference for Children and Families
needing help and support
those qualities will stand here in good
stead in the months to come
councilor Anthony had previously served
as a parish counselor for pilsley
she was elected to the district council
to represent windworth in 2011 and as a
member of winglet parish council at the
same time
she is highly regarded by councilors
from across the chamber
opposition members for example have told
me about times when Pat has ruined them
to offer assistance or to check how they
are doing when they have been ill
raise on Detra is to enhance the lives
of others
the Charities she is choosing to support
during her year in office are born from
experience and years of commitment to
enhancing the quality of lives
I am sure this will be a continuous
theme of councilor Andrews time as chair
of the council
I know she will be an outstanding
Ambassador for Northeast Derbyshire
it gives me great pride to formally
propose the councilor Pat and Cliff be
elected chair of Northeast Derbyshire
District Council for the Civic year 2020
2021 I moved
thank you can I move to Second uh that
motion
an echo and associate myself with
councilor backers remarks about Kevin's
working I know she will make a fantastic
uh chair of this Council and a really
strong representative and advocate
District Council Pat's consort will be
her sister Pamela Davenport and I know
that Pamela has been an immense support
uh to pass over the over the years and
particularly in recent years where Pat
and her family had faced some
significant emotional challenges so on
behalf of a council can I thank Pamela
for being willing to continue to support
that in this hugely important role for
the district I wish them both very well
in exercising their role at such a
difficult and strange time for the
districts and the country at large but
no as I do I'm sure they'll make the
very best of it and really do not be
establish a crowd so I'm very happy to
step in the motion
foreign thank you are there any further
nominations
if not I will now leave the council in
the vote
as a result of technical restrictions we
can only take the vote using up to 25
cameras at a time therefore we will have
to take the voting groups to see if
there is affirmation for this matter the
vote will be split into three starting
with those in the chamber plus two other
groups as follows I'll also ask
councilman Morley for his vote
I will ask each group in turn to vote
you will indicate whether you agree by
holding up your hand in screw on screen
or in the chamber
I'm going to split it in this way
counselors with surname starting with a
starting with cancer Heritage up to and
including K cancer Kerry will be asked
first councils with surname starting
with l Council Lewis up to an including
W counselor P Wright will be our second
then as I said I will ask councilor
Morley who's on the phone
so before we start can I ask everybody
in the council chamber to vote please
and counselorship I can see you
everybody in the cancer chamber is in
favor thank you
um can we make sure that only those who
are voting in the first group that is
councils with surname starting with a up
to including k for cancer Kerry
and you switch on your cameras to vote
please
Nikki have you got that
yes I have yes
thank you and can you put your switch
your cameras off and could counselors
with surnames starting with l from
councilor Loomis up to council Peter P
right would you please switch on your
cameras and vote
welcome
everybody in case we've built
foreign
Nikki have you got that
yes thank you Sarah
councilor Morley could I ask you to tell
us which way you're voting
huh Paulie has left the call right thank
you
thank you
I make that
um 26 in favor Nikki
yes agreed
that is carried
Council and Cliff you have sorry cancer
if it's therefore Julie elected as chair
of the council
[Applause]
thank you
if you have the Declaration of office
with you in the chamber I think may I
now ask that you read the Declaration
out loud and sign
Patricia have you been elected to the
office of chair of the Northeast
Derbyshire District Council prepare that
I take that office upon myself and will
Julie I'm Faithfully fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
judgments and a balancer
I undertake to observe the cultures to
the conduct which is expected of members
of Northeast Derbyshire District Council
thank you councilor and left it's over
to you now
[Music]
pass you
I will now pass you on to the leader who
will say a few words
thank you chair this is to uh
consider the service of the outgoing
chair for the last Civic here
so when taking officers chair of the
council councilor Huckabee ensured
keeping with tradition
by Falling victim to the curse of the
broken limb
she became the third chair of the
council in recent years to injure a leg
it looks back in Action Council Huckabee
with her consort husband Stewart set
about her Civic duties
these included representing this
Authority at numerous occasions
ranging from attending the induction of
the new bishop of Derby
to presenting the winners trophy at the
61st annual Brass Band Festival
she also presided over the swearing-in
of the council's first ever Civic Cadets
chose to support Sheffield Children's
Hospital packs stands for parents
Association of children with tumors and
Leukemia
as well as visiting packed house to meet
staff and patients
Carol Huckabee has endeavored to promote
awareness of the charity
during her time in office she has raised
3 400 pounds to assist their work
in spite of personal issues this year
councilor Huckabee has shown real
fortitude
as such I propose at the council places
on record its sincere gratitude for the
grace and dignity Carol Huckabee has
demonstrated as chair
along with sincere appreciation for the
support of Stuart Huckabee as her
consort
I move
I'd be very happy to uh of course Echo
the words that cancel it back in how did
you say thank you
because I invite nominations for
position or vice chair of the
future I nominate councilor Diana Ross
advised to have the council for the
Civic year 2020 2021
the published nomination of councilor
Hill as Vice chair has been withdrawn
are there any further nominations
but no further nominations the
monitoring officer will lead us in the
vote
thank you chair
can I ask everybody in the chamber to
vote please
in favor
thank you
can ask councilors with surnames
starting with a Upton including k for
councilor Kerry to switch on your
cameras and to vote please
all right
thank you
can I ask counselors with surname
starting with elf and councilor Lewis up
to including W Council P Wright to
switch on your cameras and vote
if the other cancers could please switch
off their cameras
yeah
you got that Nikki
yes I think so I've got uh seven votes
in the first 18 votes in the second and
16th
third
yeah
um
thank you
[Music]
um
now if you could switch off your
camera's chair as you heard it was
and therefore delighted to announce that
councilor Diana Ross as Julie elected as
Vice chair of the council
may I ask the governance manager to
offer a colleges for absence
thank you chair apologies for absence
today have been received from counselors
and Holmes and Clive hunt
can I also put in councilor Brian Wright
and councilor Ridgeway please
thank you those apologies have been
captured for the minutes
other animal apologies Council of
registered
member please turn the camera on
daily question and thank you that was
very nice
family members of our Declaration of
interest to declare may I ask that they
turned our cameras on
each other have been no cameras turned
on
thank you
well now considered during 196. option
of the virtual meeting standing orders
can I about the head of corporate
governance a monetary monitor to present
their report
thank you chair
on the 4th of April this year the
government temporarily removed the legal
requirement for local authorities to
hold public meetings in person this is
until May 2021
in response to a wish of this authority
to hold virtual committee meetings and
Council meetings temporary amendments
the council procedure rules are required
to enable safe management of the process
these amendments are set out at appendix
one on page seven in your original packs
and are later included in the full
review of The Constitution for
consideration on today's agenda
this has been brought for you early for
sorry this has been brought before you
early on this agenda for agreement so
that they can be implemented immediately
to assist with today's meeting
some of the changes include details that
are required to the summons for the
meeting voting and speaking rules on
rules around technical difficulties
these are backed up by the etiquette
that has been previously presented and
dispatched to members
thank you chair
thank you is there a mover yes
if members wish to comment on the report
please can you turn on your webcams now
and I will call on your intern to speak
chair no webcams have been turned on
thank you
we'll move to the boat please can the
monitoring office the leaders in the
voting process
thank you chair first of all could I ask
everybody in the council chamber to vote
if they're in favor of these changes
thank you
okay
can I ask get counselors with names
surname starting with a from cancer
Armitage up to and including Kay
councilor Kerry to switch on their
cameras and to vote
you got that
key
thank you Sarah
if you would thank you very much if
you'd switch off your car
can I now ask counselors with surnames
beginning with L and Council Lewis up to
and including W Council right to switch
on your
cameras
and vote
I believe the vote is being carried said
thank you as you heard the vote has been
carried
thank you
we are now at 197
thank you colleagues and I would like to
welcome you all to the council's first
virtual the old council meeting but you
are all keeping safe and well during
this time
I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank you for electing me as chair of
the council
I promise to undertake the role in a
fair and balanced way and right to the
best of my ability
customers to just another District I
will represent the whole of Northeast
Derbyshire and promote the interests of
the district and the people living and
working in it
I have chosen Alzheimer's research UK
and the national deaf children society
as the two Charities which will benefit
from my other two churches that which
will benefit from my chairs charity
appeal Alsina's research who care
undertaken vital work and their mission
to bring about the first life-changing
dementia treatment by 2025 by many
Founders in the district will have been
affected by the heartbreaking effects of
dementia
the national deaf children Society is a
charity I have personally supported for
a long time and I support their vision
of a world without barriers for every
deaf child I hope my appeal will help
raise money and awareness of these two
Charities and the work they do
the next item of business
we are now considering item eight
minutes of the previous two meetings of
council held on the 17th of February and
the 2nd of March 2020. before I call on
any members to speak I would like to
remind you that the minutes I've put
before us were accuracy only and the
contents are not for debate but by
November was just to comment on their
accuracy please turn on your webcam now
thank you
yeah no webcams have been turned on
okay move 12 sets of minutes
we will move to the vote please can the
monitoring office lead us in the voting
process
thank you chair could all those in the
chamber please share if they're voting
in favor
thank you
could counselors with surname starting
with a up to including those with
beginning with a k please switch on the
cameras and their vote in support of
this
is
you got that Nikki yes thank you Sarah
thank you very much if you would now
switch your cameras off
and I will ask for those with surnames
between L and A W to switch on the
cameras and shove their voting in favor
that has been carried
yeah
yes thank you
you're correct it's been carried
the next ad for business it leads us
business announcements can I write the
leader of the council to update members
of the council's response to the
coronavirus pandemic
thank you chair
well covid-19 has presented significant
challenges for the people of Northeast
Derbyshire
what the pandemic has done however is
highlight the resilience of local
residents and outstanding Community
spirit
we have all witnessed the selflessness
of key workers who have been in the
front line of combats in Coronavirus
there can never be enough words to
express gratitude for all key workers
who put their lives at risk to ensure we
are protected and essential Services
continue to be provided
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
places on record our sincere
appreciation for the many unsung heroes
who truly are saving lives and
safeguarding our way of life
in addition I wish to take this
opportunity to outline some of the
extraordinary work undertaken by our
staff and others to keep people safe and
protect local businesses as much as
possible in these unprecedented times
of the council we have implemented
business continuity arrangements to
protect people who need our help and
ensure vital services for all Northeast
Derbyshire residents
if some staff being redeployed into
different jobs overnight we have created
a community support team that has to
date
telephone
5450 people to offer assistance
delivered over 4 000 medical supplies
provided 82 food boxes
delivered 700 local newspapers and
magazines to those most isolated
contacted over 1 800 businesses to help
them access financial support
provided 1
584 grants to businesses totaling almost
18 million pounds
awarded 350 businesses 100 business
rates relief
addressed 78 environmental concerns from
residents
received twenty thousand one hundred and
eighty eight calls and emails from
residents and businesses requesting
support and advice with council tax and
business rates
had over 31 500 views of the covid-19
information section on the council's
website
received 8
265 pounds in donations to support the
district's work for others
launch the hashtag new skills challenge
to promote and teach British sign
language
sent over 220 tweets and 220 Facebook
posts reaching an audience of 360
000 views
our environmental health team has been
Central to implementing many of the
government's social distancing and
business requirements
they have been providing support to the
local business Community by sharing
advice leaflets and guidance on risk
assessments and controls necessary to
become covered secure as they strive to
reopen their businesses when permitted
so far the team has contacted
448 premises and now engaging with 163
of them
they're also working alongside
colleagues in Economic Development to
identify High Street businesses that
need our support
as a council we LED on a county-wide
project to get homeless people off the
streets
we are providing urgent accommodation
for some of the most vulnerable
including victims of domestic abuse
those with specific needs and people who
have found themselves without a home for
various reasons
we are now endeavoring to ensure this
word has a positive and sustainable
Legacy
with the objective that these people do
not end up homeless again
we will ensure support and practical
advice for them to move on positively
with their lives
as the lockdown progressed concerns
about the mental health and well-being
of people have increased
we are aware that those living by
themselves are suffering from the
negative effects of isolation and
loneliness
we are working with the Derbyshire times
to ensure weekly delivery of the
newspaper to help the isolated stay
connected locally
we placed 47 000 stickers
twice on all residence bins to keep them
updated with waste collection
arrangements and ensure every household
regardless of their ability to use it
of the council's contact details or
support and advice
The Joint working between the council
and Rick Lord Holmes has been inspiring
I have permission to share the following
examples
withheld from staff at retinal homes the
90 year old woman was supported to move
out of hospital and back into her home
help and support to restore her
independence was provided
the daughter of the tenant wrote I would
just like to say a big thank you
to Jill and Steve who helped my mother
when she came out of Hospital
they were both so kind and went out of
their way to help her
thank you both
one family wrote to the council to say I
want to send a massive thank you to all
your staff and volunteers
you have made a massive difference for
my sister in the last two weeks both
physically and mentally
following a request for help for my
sister who is mostly bedridden you
telephone her to discuss her needs
since that call things have changed so
much
she now receives a food parcel every
week and following advice about
contacting adult social care she has had
such a lot of help from the occupational
therapy bringing equipment and yesterday
at Cara coming to help her twice a day
was one of your volunteers doing dog
walking with her little dog
this has also been a huge help to her
family as we were all very worried about
her
that tried to help her from a distance
but there is a limit to what we can do
especially just now
I can honestly tell you which is amazing
how your help and kindness Has Lifted
her spirits
she was very very low and weepy two
weeks ago
but now has a smile and feels much more
positive to know that people care and
are willing to help
a massive thank you for all you are
doing
God bless every one of you
there are other examples I could share
some are heart-rending
but all of them evident how the council
and its partnership organization rignal
homes have demonstrated genuine
commitment to the people we serve
never has the council's motto which
translates from Latin as they rule will
serve meant so much
our regular meetings of Viper have
ensured a cross-party approach to
supporting our residents and businesses
I understand my sincere thanks to
counselors marker Cupid Dale Fennell
Powell and Shipman for their valued
contributions to each meeting and
working collaboratively for the benefits
of the district
the cabinet has continued to meet using
virtual means to make decisions and
maintain the core work of council at
this time
I have very much appreciated the support
and encouragement from councilors across
the chamber
many counselors have demonstrated
Community leadership and are achieving
so much for the people they represent
town and Parish councils have also
played their part
there have been fantastic engagement
with Northeast Derbyshire District
Council to share information
provide essential Services
collecting food donations games and
jigsaws
all of this evidences a huge Collective
effort which should leave us all with a
lasting sense of Pride that local
communities have tackled coronavirus
head-on a Northeast Derbyshire has shown
Unity throughout adversity
the path of covid-19 in front of us may
be long
but we as a council remain steadfast in
our resolve to book the welfare of every
resident first and foremost
thank you
thank you later the cover notebook
all right just foreign
we're over and above and we'd like to
put on record uh thanks to all the staff
but I think you've you've gone through
or you know the councilman regionals
written all for the concerted efforts
what's been quite rarely said it
unprecedented times I think
it's been used a lot but I think that's
where we are and in times like these I
think you've alluded to that
you know what things into
perspectively I think we try to
uh political difference to one side and
work constructively together to make
sure all our communities
um
I'm sure that love will eventually get
back to normal or some normality or The
New Normal is that the uh or whatever it
is that we can return to some kind of uh
Politics As We As We Know It uh or newly
and again we we want to be supportive
where we can at least a central
government but obviously we will only do
it down if we believe that the direction
detected is not you know what we think
is the best for the people in Northeast
Northeast Northeast down but thanks
again to everybody involved because it
has been unprecedented and I think as a
district council I don't think we could
do a lot more than what we've done so
thanks again
um I also want to thank the staff the
leader in the team uh they've done an
incredible amount to sa be honestly I
think a lot of it goes on notice of what
actually is happening
um and thanking all the councils as well
like you said in working in the
communities I don't know about anyone
else but the workload just shuttle of
residents that need help and it's kind
of proven while we're all elected and
what we're elected for
um and also personally want to break
Martin for inviting the operational
leaders to be a part of that is
meant that there is a a Unity approach
to all of the things that
initiate and we've all been able to kind
of explain it to Residents why things
happen and there's not being any
politics involved in that kind of
decisions that have been taking So yeah
thank you to the staff who have been
tremendous in helping me get stuff done
especially for residents so yeah it's um
really to reiterate what councilman
shipment had said and express our
support for what the council is trying
to do and I think the way that the
councils communicate responded in
receivable time has been an example I
think people will look at and look back
on in the future okay
moving on to their welcome to the
cabinet could ask the leader of the
council to advise Council of this
cabinet for the
2020-2021 in the municipal year
thank you chair the cabinet has been set
out an agenda item 10
um
so that they are my appointments for the
Civic year 2020 2021
have been noted
there are now at item 11 on today's
agenda can I invite the governance
manager to present this year's review of
The council's Constitution
thank you chair item 11 presents the
review of The Constitution which falls
into two parts as the process has been
affected by the lockdown the first group
of items have been considered by the
standards Committee in the usual way and
are reckoned recommended to you for
approval today
the second set of changes really mostly
to changes to planning committee but
there are one or two others it's
intended to invite standards committee
to consider these changes at their first
meeting and to report back if
appropriate to a future meeting of
council
these changes include the
disestablishment of the Strategic
Alliance Joint Committee
and the approval of the meeting schedule
becoming a council function
again the details are in the appendix
I'm happy to help members if they have
any queries thank you chair
thank you
yes um
yes yes I just want to play some record
first of all my thanks to the standards
committee because it's those members
who've actually put this together
so uh I mean thank them are you move the
recommendations are set out in the
report
thank you yeah
Chancellor
[Music]
could I asked a question please chair
yes
thank you Jill working councilor for
Sutton dotmington World
um I have a query about in the um
in the in the report uh appendix one
this is the report that was sent to us
on
um the 13th of May
um a delegation scheme uh which is uh to
enable officers to
um make some amendments to policies
um that is to be delegated to directors
and heads of service
um I'm a bit concerned that um officers
are being asked to quote make policies
um whereas it's normally a a council and
Leadership function I would have thought
uh an officers are responsible for
carrying out the policies
um I appreciate there is a some
pragmatic uh issues around uh but the
second point that I've got is there
doesn't seem to be any requirement for
um those changes to policies to be
reported or even to be uh to seek the
approval retrospectively possibly of the
council uh it does say on page nine of
the appendix one that he sent us
um where there is any discretionary
element to the changes uh or they are
significant these plans still be
reported to members I would have thought
that it would be a requirement for any
situation where policies have been
changed because of the demand uh if
you're talking about speed and
legislation for those to be at least as
I said yes reported to members if not
seeking retrospective approval by
members at some stage
thank you
can ask this uh Sarah September is that
just respond
hello
there yes this is very much aimed at
housekeeping type changes it's aimed at
small changes and where titles have
changed or legislation has changed in a
minor way although it actually says can
be reported the intention would always
be that anything significant would be
put to members anything that's actually
changing the policy rather than as they
say more housekeeping type things
um I would also remind you that the
delegated decision on which this the
form on which this would be made
requires consultation with the leader
Deputy leader or portfolio holders
appropriate so it couldn't be done in
the absence of members knowledge some
members knowledge anyway but as I say
the aim of this is not to fundamentally
change policies by delegation it is only
to deal with the tidying of the policies
thank you
for any further request to speak on this
item
yeah
councilor David Hancock wishes to speak
thank you chair firstly mayor
congratulate you on your election as
chair and also to congratulate you on
the job you're doing I know it's not
easy conducting sharing an actual
virtual meeting so you're doing a
marvelous job there well
um I would just actually like to raise
concern with regard to uh what's on page
eight in regards to questions and
motions and I think while we're quite
happy to uh to fully support emergency
measures during unusual times
um I have concerns that we are
restricting the scope of well increasing
the scope for rejections and also
limiting the potential for motions for
members as members obviously where we
have to adhere to the code of conduct
part of that is accountability and
Leadership and I think that these
proposed changes here actually take away
from a certainly the openness of the
council and I don't see any reason why
we can't even as a response say
unfortunately there's an ongoing
complaint we'll respond to that in due
course
um secondly the limitation of one motion
remember
it's got to be quite some time since we
have one any members submit more than
more than one motion I've been on the
council four years and I can't ever
remember there being more than four
motions on a single agenda so it's not
even like there's a long-standing or
existing problem that we need to address
um so I I do have huge concerns about
those
thank you chair thank you
yes
sir
have you anything to say
on those items they have been through
the standards committee and standards
committee have recommended them to you
for approval having considered them
thank you
we'll move to the vote please
thank you chair
um it has been interesting I do remember
it couldn't understand this committee
but and I raised concerns about it at
that point on the standards committed
that I think it's restrictive
um and if you remember the silicone
group actually put the motion on the
council last year sometime to actually
go the other way so the questions
uh so where this is making reference to
this is matching the questions at that
time we actually wanted it to go the
other way whereby the questions were
opened up to allow members to ask more
questions that basically fit rather than
you know because if you get five
questions in one month you want to be
able to go and ask those five questions
we didn't want to go in the other way
which is now subsequently happened
whereby the Motions are now matching
what the question limitation was
um so for that I would propose an
amendment if possible if that was
possible
Sarah
can we amend this
I think you moved it
yes you can propose an amendment
in in that case if I may share um I
would like to propose that
um the introduction the line that says
introducing a limitation on one motion
per member per meeting to replicate the
limits on questions is removed from this
recommendation I mean I actually agree
with 99.9 of it I just think that we we
ideally need to be open and allow
members to be as free as possible as if
they wish I mean like they like outside
looks be reference to there's not been
any test cases now where we can say oh
that's an issue we held the council
meets up for a club Australia
in front of us
um obviously you can say Well when it
does it's going to be a nightmare but I
think we have to allow members to
scrutinize we have to keep the doors
open for that to happen and I fear that
by adopting this it's probably sending
the wrong message that we're trying to
shut down through today
um which is probably not the case I
don't but I just think I I can't support
it so but I will support it we can
remove that
it's allowed my support a whole lot of
them but I just think that at this
moment in time I can't support that
so I would like to throw as an amendment
to remove that lie across
you will need to seek a seconder for
that
yes
thank you
I'm sure councilor Hancock
[Laughter]
yeah I apologize I'm struggling with my
buttons here on screen my fingers are
slipping uh I'm happy to second
in which
in which case chair we need to take a
vote on the amendment which I will take
now
um
clarification on the actual amendment
that is currently being debated
yes as I understand it it's removal of
the line referring to restricting
um uh motions to one per member per
meeting
okay
page eight on the document that's got
annual council at the top it says
motions on notice number 10. I think it
was a subsequent document saying is this
week
the the precise wording is introducing a
limitation of one motion per member per
meeting to replicate the limits on
questions
and that has been proposed Constitution
so the amendment is not to include it
yeah to remove it
not to include it
yeah just um I would just like to sort
of respond and set out my view on that I
who respect uh
and why they've raised their I don't
personally consider it to be an issue
really uh as a counterpart right he said
it's never it's never been a problem
however I think we have to respect that
there are 53 members in this chamber and
to allow a situation where one could
they haven't done yet but where one
member could put three or four motions
in uh mindful to do in a situation where
we're having to decide to guilty in a
meeting having a cut up because we can't
all be careful for hours on end so I
would suggest having a liberal like that
is helpful it doesn't stop any political
group putting in uh that many motions if
you have that many members you can put
in that emotions
but what it does do is acts as a
safeguard to prevent the future scenario
where we do have uh lots of motions we
can't get through the basic core
business because we've got to remember
the emotions at the moment come before
the core business of the meeting in the
in the meeting ages so that's my
perspective I understand the position of
the events but I would say it is still
necessary so I will be voting uh to to
keep that that wording in place
yeah yeah I I think uh are we all were
down for that on that I think we had
this debate
we've got six months ago a similar thing
about the the questions and it it does
it's a logic thing really I think that
that it just stops that one person or
taking over going on and on and on and
that and I'm I'm struggling because I
got them papers in front of me that
we're talking about a bit trying to find
them on here
but I I have credit you know I've got
the gist of that and I didn't see a big
big problem
uh so I I I tend to think
I'll go with that
and yeah and I would sort of tend to
agree and I think
we've got other functions resulted in
the council which can sort of enable us
as well as counselors I think we've got
scrutiny committees we've got standards
where we can we can start to raise raise
things as well so I wouldn't be
concerned that this will limit my
mechanisms to be able to sort of address
issues so I'm sorry I'm tending to agree
because
Dynamics
okay if I may as well I think um this
has been discussed at standards
committee so the opportunity to actually
look at this very closely has been
according to all members and it is a
cross-party meeting at standards with
Independence also there the parish
council member that I'm talking about
independent members so they've obviously
had the debate at that point and it was
still felt that a majority of the
decision from what I'm aware of is that
it should be included in this document
I have to reject that this actually
closes down scrutiny
um it does not because we have scrutiny
committees with very clear functions
about holding the administration to
account and the whole Council to account
for that matter as well as all the other
committees that we have in place to make
sure that businesses is transacted and
there is transparency around that but I
also think this is about a
proportionality situation as well for
example for the controlling group of 30
councilors all have multiple motions in
um it would be a very unwieldy for a
full Castle chamber to deal with and we
could be here for hours but also it's
about thinking about what full council's
function is Paul council is about debate
it is about examining core business but
it's also about ratification of policies
and documents that have been considered
in detail and in debt at committee stage
so I I personally don't see a problem
with this
from you
before they
've been on both on the amendments
that's correct it's now the vote on the
amendment not to include that
recommendation in the Constitution
said I think um
let me point it out if both of your
members it was in the control of it
again position in a meeting anyway
what it does though is stops opposition
people probably especially small groups
like myself and the independent group
being able to put more motions on if we
feel that there's stuff to do we aren't
necessarily going to put something we
don't feel we want to happen we want a
bit of the opportunity though I mean if
if I'm missing two people or one person
has nothing to look to emotional looking
forward even if it's somebody for in
advance what happens to the third motion
that we put in an advance Center we're
missing a member that means my soul for
my older members can't actually propose
something so that creates another
logistical problem which you don't ever
think has been tackled in this uh
proposal that what if we've already
submitted emotions in advance what
happens to that third one in my group
certain stuff which I don't think has
been considered another thing is that I
just think
obviously it might not come from the
intention of it strips and dance groups
and there may be other mechanisms within
scrutiny committed
but with all sort of scrutinous there's
some issues that can go around and
several uncommitters for months if not
years sometimes uh to the frustration of
counselors and and
if stops in the description it can be
banded around for a while and I don't
think that that's a legitimate way for
us to kind of be sent to cancer it's all
that's your root in we we are producers
to put motions forward to improve the
lives of people in this history
um so I'm gonna have to unfortunately
um reject this policy because like I say
I agree with most of it but I just
I have a problem when things when
options to councils are removed I think
we need to be allowing councils to do
more stuff
um and change the policies in the
administrator as much as possible that's
what we're all elected for uh it's
unfortunately I'm gonna have to get this
recommendation
um
[Laughter]
what did I do Sarah
can I take the vote in the chamber first
please
so who's in favor of the amendment
that's in favor of the amendment
and those against
abstentions
thank you
so I can now move on to
um everyone with whose surname begins
between a and K
if you could switch your cameras on
please
okay
first of all those in favor of the
amendment
okay Nikki
yes I can see one in favor okay
all those against the amendment
that's 18 against
18 against
and abstentions please
are there any abstentions
hey
no there are no abstentions no okay can
I have people with surnames between L
and w
ow and could all others switch the
cameras off please
does everybody switch the camera off yet
thank you okay all those in favor of the
amendment
that's one in favor
all those against the amendment
abstentions
are there any abstentions
no no
the amendment is defeated sure
thank you
come about on the original item now
can we start with the chamber please
all those in favor of the substantive
motion please
anyone against
extensions thank you
we move on to
everyone with a surname between a and K
thank you
okay all those in favor of the
substantive motion
these
that's 19.
all those against
that's one
yeah
any abstentions
no extensions
thank you can you all switch your
cameras off please and we move to those
with surnames between L and w
okay
can I have those who are voting in favor
of the motion please the substantive
motion
that's 14
.
okay 14 those against please
one
any abstentions
no no
in which case chair the motion is
carried
thank you
we are you are a Titan 12 on the agenda
and you'll have been provided by email
today with a report not to follow on the
agenda
which details the nominations to
committers can I ask questions
representatives from each of the
political Goods through Fair nominations
to the Committees and advise reviews for
the 2020-21 municipal year
nominations for the Committees
and the conservative nominations for the
outside bodies with one Amendment
the Sheffield City region combined
Authority Council representative should
we councilor Alex Dale
with myself as the substitute
and the Sheffield City region scrutiny
committee should read councilor Alan
Powell
those amendments I will be conservative
nominations
thank you
yes the labor party nominations please
for the uh for the Committees and the
outside world thank you
[Music]
sorry to interrupt there's actually just
one Amendment that's missing from ours
it's a substitute on planning should say
councilor shipment that's actually
omitted
all that is what
[Music]
we'll move to the boat please can the
monitoring officer leaders process
if I go with the chamber first please
can I take the votes for those
appointments
that's for all of the appointments thank
you
thank you
if I move to those with surnames between
a and K
can you please switch your cameras on
and can you show if you approve of your
voting in favor of the motion the
appointments thank you
that's
. and if um well yeah we'll move on to
if you could switch your cameras off
please can we move on to those between L
and L and W surnames beginning with L
and w
if you could show whether you're voting
for the motion please
that's 16
thank you emotions carriage
okay
we will now consider the appointment of
chairs and vice chairs of committees the
report outlining nominations received
there are further nominations please can
you make them known Now by turning on
your webcam
can I nominate the conservative for
chairs and vice chairs as listed
yet
thank you
shipment
[Music]
nominations set out in the paperwork
thank you
I'm tired
everybody is voting in favor
this show
thank you
if I move to those with surnames between
a and K you could switch your cameras on
please
you can show if you're voting for the
motion for the appointment
that's 20. thank you
and if you switch your cameras off
please can I take the votes of anybody
between L and w
okay
yep
thank you so that's coverage
to present the report
thank you chair
this is an annual report presented to
you at the annual meeting in order to
fulfill our statutory duty to report key
decisions taken under special urgency
rules and our obligations are set out in
the consultation Constitution to report
decisions we're calling calling has been
waived it is also to set the key
decisions threshold for the in Syrian
Municipal year
I can report that no decisions have been
taken under these rules in the last 12
months
and I can report that it is recommended
to keep the key decision level as it is
at one thousand sorry one hundred
thousand for Revenue decisions and 250
000 pounds for Capital decisions and the
recommendations in the report in the
future
thank you chairman of the
recommendations at 6.1
second year
with members would like to speak on this
item of business please can I ask for
you to turn your cameras on now
foreign
button sorry
um
monitoring officer leaders
thank you
thank you chair could everybody in the
chain though please indicate if they are
in favor of the recommendation
thank you
could those with
um surnames between beginning between NK
please switch on
my cameras
thank you and can you show whether you
support the motion or not
support emotion
but
one two three
that's 20.
thank you please
can I have those on ltw
please
those were surnames between L and W
talking
support promotion please thank you
into the Motions character
we will now move on to consider the
opponents to outside goddess yeah sure
I'd already
um preempted this one wire outlining my
amendments about Sheffield City region
so how to create your mind so um
one day
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
leaders in the voting process
testicles today was those first in the
chamber if you're in favor of the
recommendation please please show
thank you those with
surnames between a and K if you could
switch on your cameras please
okay can you please show your voting in
favor
okay Nikki
says 20.
thank you if you switch off your cameras
please
can I have those with surnames that
start between L and W switch on your
cameras please
and could you show if you're supporting
the motion
sixteen
thank you the emotions character
yeah
by the leader of the council to present
with a 400 council's calendar of meeting
score with 7
2014 year thank you chair the actual
calendar is a place of Independence to
the report you'll see that while
covering 19 is enforced we have these
wide virtual memes
we're proud as a council to show that we
are intending to continue Council
business in a transparent way so the
public knows what we're doing and the
meetings come take place as usual but
using technology
I do want to draw members to the
attention of 1.3 in the actual report
itself
we have placed some additional meetings
into the schedule on the housing
management board clay Crosstown fund
board and Joint cabinet The Joint
cabinet refers to meetings between
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
and Boles over District Council so we
have removed these strategic Alliance
joint committee so it has been
disestablished as alluded to earlier on
when we looked at the constant
The Joint cabinet meetings have already
been trialed between both authorities
we believe that it demonstrates a
leadership commitment to the Strategic
Alliance so that both cabinets can
consider projects and ways of working
um particularly when we're thinking
about economic regeneration visitor
economy and so on so um that's the way
we've decided to meet in future they
have been added to the calendar so
unless there's any comments or questions
what's up everyone
and changing the dates and times on a
regular basis or at last minute
uh it's not helpful to our members uh
and we just wanted to flag that up
really but if it's in Diaries then
people can work around them Diaries but
if we start changing then it's difficult
and you know of course quite a lot of
our members do work red lift and again
just
change the ships or whatever but I'm
sorry may I respond to that chair yes so
can I just think that's what I
completely agree with everything you
just said it's been my frustration for
years when the officers or Committees of
chairs decide to change the time but or
change the date or cancel it last minute
sometimes I know there's good reason for
that but I always believe that if
something is scheduled then everyone
should be working towards making that
happen the agenda should be put in good
time and that things should be put in
place of elected members particularly
those who have made every
um arrangement to be there because of
work commitments family commitments
whatever commitments if it's in the
diary unless there's a really really
good reason why it shouldn't be there
then that in my view PT should take
place I completely and absolutely
support your views okay I'm sure the
officers have heard what I've just said
or the officers know what I think
already
so when
um that's another thing as well for me I
am dyslexic so when times are changing
last minute because that in my head I've
got it in my head right I'm going to
that meeting I'm set up yes
but literally when it's that week and
it's changed I would have set my week
with my this is what I'm doing each day
so then when someone changes I mean
there were one committee last year that
I was on
I don't think I turned off the first six
months because that kept happening so
often that I was just missing in it went
from two o'clock in afternoon that day
after 10 in the morning so I kind of set
you know work late got later the whole
schedule were thrown out because of the
committee meetings kept changing and
that happened very regularly uh to the
point where I weren't even doing nothing
obviously representations have missed on
that particular committed so again
compared with what they were two reasons
there's something in the diary it needs
to say that I mean the whole point of
advice here it's the shake not turn up
the bad comes and shows a meeting
that's all gone to it so you know some
of it's a dire they need to stay in the
diary then we're going to come into
Works around that
well the meeting should still continue
otherwise what is a good point of advice
there and so um I again would agree with
Council Shipman's View and particularly
for reasons he's outlined as well when
people are planning for reasons or um an
expectation is there in their mind then
then obviously should make sure an
Endeavor to persuade chairs of
committees as well that meetings must
continue unless as I've already said
there's a really really valid reason and
we would hope that in that same
themselves people have good notice as to
why it's been canceled and in good time
there's nothing more frustrating than
going to meetings and then finally at
the council it's not just this Council
it's outside body doing well that we go
to sometimes we build
please
[Music]
thank you
yes I'm here sorry
um and before I do the vote um as an
officer I have noticed what you've said
and I was aware
we're just about to cancel the next bit
okay
um starting with the chamber those in
favor of the notion please show
thank you
moving on anybody with surnames between
a and K
if you can show me whether you're in
favor of the motion please
thank you if you would switch off your
cameras please
and those with um surnames Geo and W
thank you
you could show me if you're in favor of
the motion thank you
thank you chairman the Motions carried
thank you
it is a requirement of our Constitution
that the scheme of Delegation they
consider that the annual meeting of the
council the delegation scheme have been
amended as part of the wider review of
The Constitution and adopted earlier in
the meeting
therefore just as a procedural exercise
and asking members to make a formal
resolution to accept the early agreement
to the skin of Delegation and I am happy
to propose this from the chair do I have
a second second in chair
any further items on or request to speak
on this item
thanks a lot
thank you chair purely to say that
whilst we had issues with other parts of
it this part we have no issues with at
all so just to to give our support there
thank you thank you
they'll move to the boat please can the
managing up with the leaders in the
voting process
thank you chair but I start with the
chamber could all those in favor please
show
thank you
those with
sometimes getting between a and K can
you please switch on your cameras and
show me your vote if you're in favor
that's 20.
all those with surnames between L and W
if you switch on your cameras please
and show me your whether you're voting
in favor
60.
thank you thank you chairman the voters
carried motions carried
thank you
I have no electric business so program
will meet another Council and I'll be a
meeting of the Council of the control
is
foreign
[Music]
we will begin
we will begin today's ordinary meeting
of Council on the agenda is apologies
for absence
the governor is manager will now offer
given apologies
thank you chair the same apologies are
in from the previous meeting
um recently held that's councilor homes
Council hunt councilor Elliott Castle
Ridgeway and councilor B Wright
okay
definitely notice
thank you Declarations of interest
to the class
reading
[Music]
um
no further announcement so let's move on
to the next selection
until the next item public participation
I can confirm that no questions have
been submitted
Canyon
oh sorry thank you
hopefully they are older or environment
to present the report on silence
uh thank you chair uh councilor Kenyan
eckington law this Charter is to ban the
release of sky lanterns and helium
pollution Council and Whitmore land you
clear it's not about a child
accidentally letting go of a single
balloon at home
the danger the sky lanterns are obvious
you're sending the lightest flame out
across housing Estates Woodlands daihi
car parks and so on they're designed to
burn out before landing but the reality
is they sometimes touchdowns still
burning and for example a huge fire in
the Midlands was caused by a sky lantern
resulting in millions of pounds of
damage he also leave little which can be
accidentally eaten by animals including
metal and plastic parts I myself have
picked up two old people in balloons in
the scout
by adopting this Charter we send a
signal to our residents this will be
accompanied by messaging to explain the
new policy and why and to suggest
alternative ways of celebrating in
addition we can then engage with our
schools and Lobby our NP and ask that
the address issue is addressed by
Parliament so I moved up the
recommendations
[Music]
thank you
concentrated
thank you I'm happy to fully second that
and endorse all of councilor kenyan's
comments I think he's made the points um
of how serious this issue issue is very
well
thank you
please come members wishing to speak on
the side to make it no more turning on
their cameras
foreign
having a permission for policing is at
this stage what we do know is that the
public are very Vigilant about this I
think councilors have received many
emails and correspondence from residents
who are extremely concerned about
healing balloons under the use of
skylances
and um so we know that out there the
public are our eyes and ears and they
will certainly report people who are
actually disregarding this as a council
policy so while we can't stop helium
balloons and Skylanders in general
across Northeast Derbyshire what we can
do as a council is permitted on our
property and our land and I think it's a
clear message to everybody across the
district that we are against guidance
has been used in this way in helium
balloons but concerned not just about
financial implications and damage
perhaps secondary to me it's about a lot
of animal-like Wildlife all these sorts
of things we hear all sorts of good
stories about pets who've been injured
by these things as well as our local um
animals and so on so I think I think we
need to make a stance
support
councilor Windsor
immune system
okay sorry
um yeah I fully support this as well
it's been a long time concern of mine
the use of these
anthems and I fully support it it's a
it's a good motion
gonna further request to speak on this
item concept
just to reach out really the the whole
group actually supports this notion
although as a liberal I'm usually
reserved in buying things I think that
in this case it affects all those what's
up what I've got the actions of using
these and therefore
um absolutely supported and I think it's
a random for the constitute on its own
property obviously we can't tell other
people what they're doing their own
property but we can what we can do is
accounts to say it's not having on our
land and I think it's the right just one
question I'm sure you've got answers
okay
[Music]
so
thank you chair
um I'm actually just just got a really
kind of half a dress Nigel's point he's
saying how do we police it we we do have
the options here of CPW cpns so we're
not impotent on this it is a first step
but we already have things that can go
forward to police if we need to and I
think obviously we need to send out the
message that we're going to do so uh
welcome to to Jeremy and Charles putting
this forward
um but absolutely support it and yes we
we can police it we can do that well
yeah
thank you
any further requests to speak
we'll move to the boat please can the
monitoring office leaders in the voting
process
thank you chair could I take the vote in
the chamber first please
always in favor
thank you now everybody with the surname
beginning with an a to K can you please
switch your cameras on please
and show me if you're voting in favor
foreign
could you switch your cameras off please
and now everybody with surname between L
and w
thank you can you show me if you're
voting in favor
thank you chair the Motions carriage
thank you
I can confirm that no questions have
been submitted for this meeting so let's
move to the next item
thank you
yes
exclusion of the public
I will now move that department
be experience
of business to avoid the disclosure to
them other exempt information as defined
in paragraphs one two three and five
part one of schedule 12a to the Local
Government Act 1972 as amended by the
local government
access to information variation ordered
the second year thank you
we'll move to the vote please can the
monitoring officer leaders in the voting
process
all those in favor in the chamber please
show
thank you is everybody